Let's take a look at how the death police worked in the time since Furman versus
Georgia held that it was unconstitutional.
And then 1976,
Greg versus Georgia held,
uh,
that it was constitutional.
1976 the court upheld the so called guided discretion statutes let states have
the depth pony as long as jury's head discretion,
whether to impose it struck down the mandatory death pony statutes.
And those have been the case,
the statutes that we've had since 1976.
Uh,
there've been some reservations expressed about how well the death penalty has
worked,
whether all of the fixes that,
uh,
were advocated to what it was said in 1976 that the problems that Fermin
identified,
the arbitrariness and the death pony,
the racial discrimination and other factors had been corrected.
Well,
uh,
in 1994 and probably one of the first major questionings of the death pony,
a Justice Harry Blackmun who was appointed to the Supreme Court,
uh,
by President Richard Nixon and who voted to uphold the death polling in the firm
and case was one of the four dissenters and Ferman voted to uphold the death
pony in all of the 1976 cases and repeatedly voted to uphold the death pony for
a number of years,
uh,
announced in the case of Collins Versus Collins,
that he would,
as he said,
no longer tinker with the machinery of death.
Uh,
justice black when explained that the court's decisions that mitigating
circumstances,
anything about the life and background of the accused could be taken into
account,
uh,
made it almost impossible for there to be consistency in the imposition of the
death penalty.
Uh,
he found the consistency was constitutionally required,
but he found that the requirement that anything be considered in mitigation,
uh,
really put these two constitutional guarantees,
intention with one another,
uh,
and made it almost impossible,
to have a consistently applied death pony.
Of course,
there are a lot of other reasons for that.
The discretion exercise by prosecutors,
the quality of lawyers better in some cases than others.
Uh,
lots of other factors that contributed to it.
he also expressed,
uh,
his dismay,
that the court had gone back on some many of the procedural protections that
exist in particularly habeas corpus review,
which existed in 1976 but which the court kind of relentlessly cut back on until
1996 when Congress then,
uh,
past the antiterrorism and effective death penalty act,
which greatly restricted,
uh,
the power of the federal courts to grant review and cases.
So he comes to the conclusion that the death penalty for all these reasons.
Also the fact that race,
uh,
that didn't McCluskey versus Kemp,
the Supreme Court had said that a certain amount of racial discrimination was
tolerable,
uh,
in the imposition of the death penalty.
He says at this point,
I will no longer a tinker with a machinery of death.
Uh,
Justice Scalia,
uh,
response in a dissent,
he reasserts the position that he been asserting for some time before this case
came down in 1994 and that was,
uh,
that the court shouldn't allow sentences to consider anything about the life and
background of the defendant in mitigation,
that the state should be able to restrict what could be considered in
mitigation.
So,
uh,
basically there's a back and forth between the two of them.
This was not a case that the court decided this was a case in which the court
denied review of the case.
And Justice Blackmun wrote a dissenting opinion saying,
uh,
I would grant review and vacate the death penalty for all these reasons because
I think the death penalty is unconstitutional.
Justice Scalia just wrote a statement,
concurring saying that he did not agree with justice.
Blackmun's critique a of the death penalty.
I,
this was going to happen again,
uh,
in the case of bass versus Reese,
which was,
uh,
the lethal injection case out of Kentucky,
in his opinion in which she upheld lethal injection,
saying that under the court's precedent,
he thought that what Kentucky was doing did not violate the constitution.
Uh,
justice Stevens,
uh,
look back on his career on the court.
He was appointed by President Ford.
Uh,
he served,
uh,
he was alive at the time of Greg,
and it's still alive.
Uh,
when,
when he handed down this decision in,
in,
in Bays,
uh,
he said he had come to the conclusion,
that the problems with the death punny,
that justice white identified in his concurring opinion in Furman versus
Georgia.
We're,
we're in fact just as accurate today as they were then,
that the duck plenty was shoes.
So Seldomly,
uh,
so arbitrarily,
that,
uh,
race was still a factor,
in,
uh,
whether or not the death penalty was used or not.
Uh,
that as he put it,
the needless extinction of life with only marginal contributions,
uh,
to any discernible social or public purpose was patiently excessive and
violated.
The eighth amendment that is there was just as just as white said,
the way in which the death planes being imposed is serving almost no value to
society.
Some people are getting it,
some people aren't.
There's no reason,
principled reason why some are in some art,
and therefore it's an excessive and cruel and unusual punishment.
Um,
Justice Scalia responded to justice Stevens justice.
He had responded to justice Blackmun.
Uh,
he said,
would it look like what Stevens was saying was that if the punishment wasn't
retributive enough,
uh,
it wasn't retributive at all.
Uh,
he also said and made two arguments that the supporters of the death pony,
uh,
have made and continue to make,
one that some crimes are such an affront to humanity,
uh,
that the only response is the death penalty.
A,
this is what Justice Stewart said,
uh,
way back in Greg versus Georgia,
that,
uh,
they're just some crimes that this is the way they should be punished.
And finally,
he said that it should be left up to the legislatures.
Actually,
a number of legislatures have taken action on the death penalty.
Uh,
five states that once had the death penalty have repealed it.
in addition to that,
New York's Court of Appeals declared the New York death penalty
unconstitutional,
uh,
in the 1990s,
has been no effort to bring the death pony back.
Uh,
in New York,
a governors of three states,
Colorado,
Oregon,
and Washington,
uh,
have declared Moratoria on the death penalty in their states saying that they
were not,
it didn't stop the death plenty.
They didn't commute the sentences,
but they said,
we're not gonna allow anybody else to be executed until we've studied and given
us a greater thought.
Uh,
in addition,
other people have raised reservations about the death pony.
President Jimmy Carter was governor of Georgia in 1973 when Georgia's death
penalty law was passed after it had been declared unconstitutional the year
before in Fermin,
uh,
in November of 2013,
President Carter,
uh,
announced that he was opposed to the death pony.
He was opposed because it was,
he said it was being,
uh,
the people getting the death polling where the poor,
the mentally limited,
uh,
and because of race entering in to the factor,
entering in as a factor,
uh,
he made that speech at,
the Carter Presidential Library.
Uh,
and it's on the website,
uh,
of the library.
Uh,
other people have raised questions.
A number of death sentences in the country has declined.
Uh,
so there will continue to be an ongoing debate in some legislatures and somewhat
in the courts,
uh,
about the appropriateness of the death public.
The supporters of the death penalty,
uh,
say that it is appropriate in a few cases,
particularly the heinous cases.
Of course,
we've seen that it's not always limited to those cases,
but the argument of course is that it should be.
Uh,
but of course when each prosecutor gets to decide in each judicial district all
over the country,
that may not always happened.
The violent crime rate,
uh,
particularly for murder has gone down.
Uh,
some attribute that,
uh,
to the presence of the death penalty,
some say that these trends are irrelevant to the death penalty.
Uh,
some prosecutors have argued that they have to have the death penalty in order
to get plea bargains to life imprisonment without parole.
That the death penalty can be used as sort of bludgeon people into guilty pleas.
Of course,
there are a number of states that no longer have the death penalty,
uh,
that seemed to get plea bargains,
even without it.
Uh,
and there's some ethical moral question about whether the death plenty can be
used.
Uh,
just to try to get plea bargains out of people,
uh,
to say to someone,
if you don't take the plea offer,
we're going to get the death penalty,
give you the death pony.
Because if that's the case,
if the person turns down the plea offer a then the prosecutor has to seek the
death penalty to make good on the,
on the threat.
And someone who was never really seen as appropriate for the death.
Pawnee ends up on death row.
Uh,
so,
uh,
Josh,
Marcie has said,
well,
the depth pony is arbitrary,
but so is homicide.
Uh,
deaths are arbitrary.
so we shouldn't worry as much about the death penalty.
Uh,
there's of course a debate about whether innocent people have been executed.
many of the proponents of depth,
plenty say there has never been justice Scalia particularly.
You said there's never been innocent person executed.
Uh,
some of the opponents have taken exception to that and say Carlos de Luna that
if you read what Jim Liebman and others have written about Carlos de Luna,
uh,
he was probably the wrong man.
It was probably another man named Carlos who committed the crime.
A Todd Willingham,
the,
the fellow convicted of arson,
uh,
killing his own children in Texas.
Uh,
it may have been an accidental fire,
may not have been arson,
but these arguments,
uh,
continue to,
go on,
um,
DNA evidence.
Uh,
now that we have DNA evidence,
we don't make as many mistakes as we used to make.
Woody and evidence DNA evidence has certainly shown that a lot of mistakes had
been made,
uh,
in capital and non capital criminal cases.
Uh,
the problem is the DNA evidence and bodily fluids that are subject to DNA
evidence are only available in about 10% of cases.
So in those cases,
there's blood or hair or semen or some other bodily fluid or hair,
whatever,
uh,
which can be tested.
Uh,
but in the other 90%,
there isn't a,
and we still have the issues of misidentification and a false testimony from
informants and other things that contribute to innocent people being accused and
sometimes,
uh,
convicted of crimes.
Uh,
the other argument is that there's this review of the death by automatic appeal
once somebody sends to death at trial.
There's an automatic appeal to the state Supreme Court.
There's a long drawn out review process in both the state courts and then in the
Federal Habeas Corpus courts.
Chris,
one of the reasons that Justice Blackmun,
uh,
announced his opposition to the death pony after going along with it for so many
years was the fact that Habeas Corpus review had been cut back so much and would
be cut back even more with the passage of the antiterrorism and effective death
penalty act,
which established the statute of limitations which has been missed.
And over 50 death penalty cases,
meaning people got no review whatsoever if their cases,
uh,
by the federal courts.
Uh,
but in theory,
uh,
that review as possible,
of course,
the court's review only the issues that are preserved,
the issues where objections were made,
where,
uh,
something was,
challenged,
uh,
somebody has a bad lawyer,
very often,
unfortunately,
uh,
that doesn't happen.
Uh,
and then finally,
the high quality of representation,
uh,
for people facing the death pony.
I don't mean to take these apart just for the sake of doing it.
Uh,
but unfortunately the quality of lawyers representing people in the death
penalty cases,
uh,
has been a disgrace.
A three cases in Houston where lawyers slept during the trial,
uh,
cases where lawyers who missed the statute of limitations were then appointed to
represent people at trial where people who,
uh,
were just absolutely a incompetent by any standard continue to be appointed in
case after case after case,
uh,
by,
judges particularly in Texas and Alabama and some of the states that send the
most people to death row.
I think when it comes to the support for the death pony,
you come back to the two points that Justice Scalia made a in the base case,
uh,
one,
that there are some crimes that are just so heinous that some people would say
those crimes have to be punished,
uh,
with the death penalty.
Uh,
and second,
that it's up to the legislature's,
uh,
to decide,
whether or not society should have the death,
plenty of not,
or whether or not a particular state should have the death penalty or not.
Uh,
but there have to be caveats with that,
uh,
that if there are those crimes,
that are so heinous that the death penalty is imposed,
then there needs to be amendments to definitely statutes to limit the death
penalty,
uh,
to those crimes.
Uh,
right now,
uh,
convenience store robbery,
somebody goes into a convenience store,
robs a store,
police officers respond,
or the person at the store,
uh,
responds or a customer comes in for whatever reason someone is killed.
And the process of that,
it's horrible,
tragic.
And the person should be prosecuted and the person should certainly be punished
for what they did.
Uh,
but there are a lot of cases like that and only a few of them,
uh,
end up with a death pony.
So those are not that,
uh,
the serial killers,
the mass murders are people like that.
Uh,
Timothy Mcveigh's,
uh,
that people imagine a,
for the death pony when they say it's reserved for certain cases where only the
death penalty should be imposed.
Uh,
and the other is there certainly has to be a commitment to make sure that in
every death penalty case,
the person who's facing the death,
Tony is adequately represented at every stage of the process.
If people are not represented by competent counsel at trial,
uh,
if they're given an incompetent lawyer for the review process,
who misses the statute of limitations,
thereby depriving them of any review of their case by the federal courts,
uh,
then a lot of these arguments drop out of the picture,
because,
uh,
they're not there.
Uh,
and yet there's not really,
uh,
the effort about the land and in the states that still have the death point to
try to limit it to the absolute worst of the worst,
the most heinous cases.
Uh,
and in many places,
particularly the ones that impose it more,
most often,
Texas being the most often,
uh,
the quality of legal representation,
is dismal.
And so that's where we are with the death.
Plenty of the United States,
uh,
it has a lot of problems.
Uh,
it's still arbitrary.
it's still imposed primarily upon poor people,
upon people who commit their crimes against white people,
uh,
much more often against people of color,
people of African American,
Mexican,
Hispanic,
other,
uh,
ethnicities.
Uh,
and very often as was dealt with in another segment,
uh,
imposed upon people who are intellectually disabled.
It is mentally retarded,
or people who are profoundly mentally ill.
Uh,
and so,
uh,
that's the death only,
that we have in the United States of America today.